une du crack depuis que j'ai 15 ans je
des joints
boit de l'alcool en vivent ailleurs
n'importe quoi doit les amis du couvent
et du francilien lui tombé à cause
d'abord et du crack de la journée maman
me sens prêt à lancer deux colosses
d'eau potable ce que tu sais y'a pas que
l'islam
déjà qu'ils se trouvent des artistes
inconnus cherche à voir du jour au
lendemain on peut tous basculé dans une
dans la misère des gens
êtes vous m
je vous emmène aujourd'hui pour brut sur
la colline du crack
depuis plus de dix ans dealers et
consommateurs de crack se donnent rendez
vous
historiquement la colline du crack se
trouve ici à porte de la chapelle au
nord de paris
coincé entre les échangeurs de
l'autoroute a1 et le périphérique en
novembre 2019
le coin est évacuée et quelques semaines
plus tard les deux mille habitants se
réinstalle juste 500 mètres plus loin à
porte d'aubervilliers
le lieu une réputation violente mais
j'ai voulu vous raconter des parcours et
vous montrer les visages de celles et
ceux qui tombent d'y survivre
[Applaudissements]
où
3 et vous
on savait depuis connu là bas tu vois
le 4 ou le toit du jour on essaie de te
ramasses mans troyes où le personnel non
pas pour nous
voilà ça nous motive
[Applaudissements]
une chose est claire
j'étais à shaker
on pouvoir nettoyer la saleté tout le
monde en somme sa vie
un fois je sais
g
c'est en fait que c'est
pas content
je suis bloqué tous les bateaux
je suis bloqué
un chemin plus long
chez par nous parce que
c'est touchant
/
je suis choyé les médias oublient le
vent
puis pour le mans
mais le monde
et c'est de maîtriser d'assad yeux
cherche à faire c'est tout un travail
ce sont les immigrés sont à 8 g après
larry fallu mettre leur temps on suit le
cours a cédé la place aux jeux est ce
qu'on avait pitié on a du mal de ce pôle
est maintenant une mycose salvini
toxicomanes aussi
est ce qu'on les a envoyés tout droit
dans la merde c'est pour sortir dans son
pays devenir de yogi comme ça c'est
malheureux les migrants dont parle ni
allen ils ont été évacués de tous les
camps nord de paris
c'est comme ça qu'ils se sont retrouvés
ensuite sur la colline du crack
[Applaudissements]
ah oui à tout
et pour ça le jour
celle ci
détruis outré par ces témoins
causé med
ce que vous aimez les arts est
intéressant et puis ce que je pouvais
tendu
poteau qui veut
vous utilisez de nuit
qui étaient les cibles
les uns ont quittés
vous savez voir boubala si peu marre aux
jeunes qui tout à fait mais là j'arrive
on peut chuter
on peut citer sans sans saveur du jour
au lendemain on peut tous basculé dans
une dans la misère les gens se voilent
la face
chez eux et ce suite aux médicaments à
l'alcool les jeunes et ce suite au shit
à la cocaïne
c'est aussi des addictions c'est aussi
de la drogue c'est pas pour autant
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à assurer à
l'école au boulot ou dans leur vie de
famille eh ben on est pareil
[Applaudissements]
le crack en fait on l'appelle la drogue
du pauvre c'est un dérivé très bas de
gamme de la cocaïne mélangée avec du
bicarbonate de soude et de l'ammoniac
sur la nouvelle colline je rencontrais
laurie une jeune belge de 19 ans qui est
devenu accro au crack très jeune mais à
israël des allures garder des calèches
des souvenirs et 10 ans augustin binya
et les volets ouest
ap toutefois mes parents m'en veulent
pas une fois elle parce que je rédige
avait arrêté de fumer
je suis en france
ça te fait que l'excès
là ça me fait plus grand chose
on va voir
je
je connais depuis que j'ai 15 ans
ça fait quatre ans que je suis mme du
crack et après trois ans et demi que je
suis là mais pour autant je retournais
chez ma mère et tout mais je suis jeune
caisse
c'est un
j'aimerais pas que
nagel son épouse
vous
je n'ai pas
j-1 me faisais
ces journées jeune fille
oui
ce que tu sais y'a pas que du ca déjà
qui souffre des artistes alain konig des
gens juste perdu je crois parce que je
sais être trouvé
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est mes dessins le corps d'une
femme
alors voilà mon histoire est assez
longue ce triste eh ben mon père pendant
un week-end sur deux me tripotait de mes
deux ans mais si zoé ni de mes 6 ans et
demi avait sept ans et demi c'était du
viol au moins porter plainte avec moi
classé sans succès et m'ont placé dans
un centre pédopsychiatrique car j'avais
du mal
maman avait un nouvel homme à nouveau
bébé nouvelle maison génial après à 13
en sucre est née dormir dans des avec
des punks à chiens anarchiste qui m'ont
emmené effet boutique le fameux krach
fort sa chapelle
moi quand je suis parfois je te vends ma
grand mère elle ne suffit pas aller vers
la lumière d'où elle vient
nous
[Applaudissements]
ok c'est un faux
ce que je pensais
cité du côté de bain
si tu as 50 balais bambins
surtout il n'y a pas de l'histoire enfin
qu'ils avaient
mais sache est tombé
papa de l'argent d'un papa
[Applaudissements]
1° un nouveau club
on n'a pas validé
je vais la manif voyard c'est la foire
tu veux faire ça ou
malheureusement l'histoire de loris et
pas du tout une exception sur la colline
les habitants de la colline sont
régulièrement expulsés et ça ne fait que
déplacer le problème
en réalité pour quitter le crack il
faudrait pouvoir quitter la colline mais
beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont nulle part où
aller
et ici c'est leur seule famille c'est
souvent les faiblesses et les frères et
mes défauts
j'y vais c'est une fumée du feu
jérôme daliot à ma femme le dis que j'ai
fait les gens s'aiment beaucoup ici bien
qu'ils sont bien entendu que la mise et
à la divisent mais est encore d'amour
ici bébé chez moi confiance rebondit
modérément
[Applaudissements]
à changer l'état paseo
nationaux japonaise doit bien
tenesol
là moi car mon époux la solide
modérateur
[Applaudissements]
chalon
hier